- pg-13 that came out of left field
everything leaks in this town how did
this not leak Ryan Reynolds and his
studio but I will give the credit to
Ryan Reynolds more than anybody else
it's extraordinary at figuring out ways
to get around the system and be clever
both in terms of getting attention when
it comes to viral stuff and in terms of
deflecting attention when it comes to
something like this and so in the same
way that Beyonce or Kanye can drop an
album out of nowhere
Ryan forgot a way that to drop a movie
kind of out of nowhere
is pretty amazing it's crazy it's crazy
everything leaks like you actually made
the announcement with nobody knowing I
am stunned by this and I haven't even
heard about it and I hear it anyway but
I'm not trying to put myself in this
with he posted this picture of him and
Fred in bed and it looks Princess
variety is that the conceit of the of
the movie where it's him them to talking
over like cutting over the raunchy stuff
dude you just asked me how we kept it
secret okay do you represent - my answer
meaning but so basically when do you
think we're gonna see a trailer 0% - man
it's pretty okay nothing on that other
than my admiration for the way of the
Ryan mess and the studio has managed to
keep it a secret up to this point I
completely understand I at least tried
yes you did uh no Holly how dr. new
movie what's the status that he's
writing it right now he's directing a
different movie and so that's his focus
is directing the movie and obviously
working on season three of Allegiant
yeah Legion is fantastic for people who
are not watching like love that show
thank you no as a genius I agree with
that statement he is a brilliant right I
needs a lovely guy - nice combination